il était une fois un petit prince qui
habitait une planète à peine plus grande
que lui les multiples c'est un beau
projet et c'est un projet ambitieux est
à la fois touchant et émouvant parce que
il nous raconte quelque chose des
souvenirs très personnels déjà
moi j'ai beaucoup beaucoup aimé j'ai été
très touché par le film et c'est voilà
c'est l'oeuvre qui parle d'elle-même et
a pas d'autre discours dans ce cas là
c'est vraiment ça qui prime quoi moi
j'ai adoré le livre et le hail et le
film donc c'est difficile de pas y aller
quand même s'il vous plaît dessine moi
un mouton on se lance oui c'est parti
moi c'est le petit prince et andré basse
et la biennale tard j'ai donné un tout
petit bouton panique ça s'est endormi
l'histoire et les vues de de façon très
très différentes à la fois c'est le
petit prince de l'aviateur comprendre et
qui parle comme on le voit dans le dans
le dans le livre mais c'est aussi à
travers le monde dans lequel on vit
aujourd'hui à travers les yeux d'une
petite fille qui est dans un monde
extrêmement ferme et mathématiques
rigoureux et personnage de clara est
vraiment le personnage pivot dans ce
film c'est ce qui permet de réunir le
petit prince et le film le petit prince
qui on le rappelle différent du du livre
qui est un film dans le film pas une
histoire dans l'histoire
aimait beaucoup les couchers de soleil
la double histoire fait que ça apporte
quelque chose de nouveau il ya un nouvel
imaginaire qui vient s'y greffer sans
trahir l'oeuvre
voyons ça de plus près la minute de
l'heure l'heure du jour le jour de la
semaine de la vie alors je suis la mère
clara on dirait pas je sais je pourrais
de sa soeur magie de l'animation
donc on ne peut plus se permettre aucune
boulette comme lors de l'entretien
d'accord
un jour tu deviendras un adulte
formidable merci même la côte est assez
robotics est froid mais finalement elle
est habitée quand même par cette envie
de bien de bien faire pour sa fille elle
elle veut le meilleur pour elle voilà
donc c'est quelque chose que tout les
mais reconnaissent sur quelle planète
suis tombé sur la tête en afrique elle
serpent sait jamais si les méchants
réellement aux cils ou s'il se présente
un peu comme un scorpion qui est que de
nature il peut mordre mais je suis plus
puissant que le doigt d'art tu ne
m'aimes pas de pain tu ne peux même pas
voyager c'est un vrai travail de
création
il faut se mettre dans la peau du
personnage ou plus souvent c'est ça qui
est dur c'est ce que font rentrer dedans
et toi c'est est divisible quelques fois
c'était difficile on priait ou deux oui
mais c'est naturel on s'en fait c'est
naturel pu rentrer dans le personnage
surgi concentre sa marche pas fort vire
faut rester concentré
mais auquel jouent avec moi je ne peux
pas jouer avec toi je ne suis pas
apprivoiser absolument divin c'est
sublime
c'est d'une poésie rare et séquelles
qu'elle riche idée d'avoir fait le petit
prince comme saab l'imagination vraiment
est sollicité à tout moment et puis des
dessins seront tellement magnifique et
on a cette diversité ou dans la
réalisation de deux de diverses façons
de faire le dessin animé la différence
des deux traitements plus permet de ne
jamais donner l'impression qu'on usure
ou contrail oeuvre et c'est vraiment
très beaux essais c'est vraiment
audacieux d'avoir d'avoir réuni deux
sortes d'animations c'est super rare et
c'est vraiment une idée magique pour qui
a eu le réalisateur du film merci je
n'ai pas d'histoire